hey guys in this video I want to talk
about the nine top super foods on the
planet okay we're talking about kale
firms now kale is very bitter anything
bitter is really good for your liver in
removing fat from the liver in
decongestant the gallbladder making more
bile so it's basically you want to start
consuming more vegetables than are
bitter most of these are better but kale
has tons of vitamin C vitamin K vitamin
A but mainly what it will do is it helps
to slowly clean and detoxify your liver
alright it's also anti estrogenic too so
if you have a buildup of excess estrogen
the bad kind
it'll help balance that okay cabbage so
this is the l-glutamine that's a thin
nutrient that's really good for your
brain it's good for the heart it's good
for the muscle it's good for leaky gut
cabbage juice is wonderful for healing
ulcer and anything related to an
irritable bowel even acid reflux or
heartburn cabbage is really good for
that
Brussels sprouts Brussels sprouts are
very similar to cabbage they're like
almost the same properties but what's
interesting about Brussels sprouts as
they do not have any negative effects on
your thyroid because sometimes the
cruciferous vegetables are currently bad
for your thyroid because they deplete
iodine well you'd have to eat a lot of
them but what I like to do is I just
like to recommend having some seek help
with these vegetables and then you're
good to go
but Brussels sprouts have all the
effects that cabbage has but without the
thyroid negative aspects okay so now we
get to the radish radish is really high
in sulfur so it's it's really good to
help detoxify the liver us specifically
chemicals and poisons that are actually
in the liver and helps to eliminate them
support something called phase 1 phase 2
detoxification which basically you take
a poison and turn it into a
water-soluble particle for you it's
eliminated safely through the body
but radishes are really good for sinus
mucus congestion because they help pull
out mucus especially the Spanish black
radish but you can take them for a sinus
congestion you can take them for deep
mucus and the lungs that just can't come
out it's a really good anti mucus thins
and mucus then we get the beet okay
beets the deep top is really good for
potassium like it has that most
potassium any other vegetable but the
actual beet is good as well
why because beet is loaded with nitric
nitric oxide and nitric oxide is good
for decreasing tension in the arteries
decreasing blood pressure helping
increase testosterone and balancing on
estrogens so that's just one of the many
functions but it's really good for the
liver in the gallbladder then we get
asparagus asparagus has not just fibre
to feed the colon but it's very
anti-anxiety it's good for relaxation
it's good for stress it's loaded with
vitamin b1 I like to take asparagus when
I take it I noticed that I'm really calm
after I consume it like the day after I
just feel really calm so I recommend
that it's also good as an antipyretic it
pushes fluid out it's good to prevent
kidney stones it has a lot of great
things garlic of course we know about
garlic garlic is the most potent
anti-cancer antiviral antibacterial
antifungal and Dyess it just cleans up
bad microbes in your system and it
prevents issues that I can't really make
claims in this video but you can look it
up but it's really just a good immune
builder turmeric is it a powerful
anti-inflammatory agent it's good for
the brain it's considered an anti-aging
nutrient okay and then we have parsley
parsley is another one of my favorites
it's kind of the garnish that no one
eats but parsley has more vitamin A than
kale it has three times the vitamin C
the two oranges it has twice the iron
spinach has so it's it's like a
superfood it has massive amounts of
vitamin K so I will take the parsley
combine it with kale with lemon juice
and make my kale shake like that but
it's very bitter good for the liver but
these are the top superfoods that I
think are the absolute best ones on the
planet so hope you enjoy this now the
other time is to apply this information
and start eating these foods I'll see in
the next video